since we've spoken you have set a record
and a very uh interesting unique
offering of an equity crowdfunding
on republic five million dollars raised
in
i think five days or three days i'm not
sure tell everybody what you did on
republic um we just i cannot from
republic
yeah can um so it's actually not
exactly five days but it was uh we did a
reg cf
march 15th you know the the amount went
up from 1.07 million to 5 million that
was the cap that can be raised there
and we took advantage of that and so we
did
we we did do the fastest on republic
first
million uh ironically enough because
that's the name of my podcast
so the first million was the fastest
that had
been on the on republic which was eight
hours and then
um there was a waiting list that had
about a million on it and then march
15th
in about seven days we raised three
million
wow to be a total of five incredible and
in talking to ken it was a unique
structure because
this wasn't to be an lp in your fund to
invest in
black founders or founders of color how
do you like to say it
it's it's is it they're they're two
they're not the same necessarily they
can be the same but they're not so black
founders can be people of color but not
all people of color are black
so it's depending on what you mean right
what you'll what's the mandate of the
fund so we invest
in women across the board people of
color
and lgbtq founders perfect
uh so i i strike out on all three counts
yeah yeah well you know yeah well we've
been
we've been over represented as white
dudes yeah every once in a while we have
a sandbox for over represented and we
rarely use it
so yeah so this was an interesting thing
because what you actually saw was
not uh to be an lp in your fund which
unfortunately in the united states is
still not allowed if you're poor
or even middle class or upper middle
class or even
affluent you're not allowed to be an lp
in a venture fund it's crazy
yeah you can be making 180k a year by
all by no means is that poor
um and you're not allowed because you
don't reach that 200k
threshold or 300k with a spouse it's
bonkers
and and hopefully the sec works on it
but you sold
10 percent of backstage which is i guess
your holding company
so or backstage capital or back
yeah sure our reg cf was for backstage
capital and and i do hesitate because we
do have uh
kind of a mirror uh two entities but
it's in exchange for 10 total
carry of our sorry uh 10
total share of our carry and management
fee
so carry retroactively for funds that
were retroactively built
and management fee moving forward and of
course the carry is
is where we hope that the the real money
comes from uh management fee will be
nominal especially at that amount but
will be um
it's part of it and that's a big deal
you know yeah i mean it would be the
equivalent of
you know i don't know pick a fund my
fund or whatever
and you're on your second fund i think
or a third fund so we have
we just kind of look at it the first few
we have small
funds that were like technically spvs
and so we are we have about 14 million
dollars
raised over across to a couple of those
so mark cuban put in
almost 6 million and then the rest of it
where these like
nano funds and then moving forward
um we are starting kind of over at
opportunity fund one
because it is it gets really confusing
for people because they hear fund four
and they think oh you have a lot under
management are you you know very you
have
very seasoned but it really is like we
put together
that first real angel fund and now we're
going out for the bigger fund